salary ranges have come to New York City
job postings this month a new salary
transparency law took effect that
requires most employers to provide good
faith salary ranges on job posts the
significance of all of this is huge pay
information has been secret for decades
but since the legislation went into
effect job Seekers are finding that some
companies are sidestepping the new
regulation by listing salary ranges so
wide that they stretch hundreds of
thousands of dollars so does this
loophole mean New York City's new law is
ineffective
pay transparency laws exist to different
degrees in some states in the U.S but
Colorado and now New York City stand out
in that they require this information in
job postings experts say New York City's
salary disclosure law may be especially
impactful because of the size of the
city's economy and the number of
companies there New York City is now the
biggest job market in the U.S to require
employers to list pay ranges and job ads
this law has National implications
because if a job could conceivably be
done in New York employers would have to
comply with it and that applies to
remote roles as well and already we're
starting to see companies across the U.S
begin to list pay for remote roles
wanting to comply with the New York
legislation officials say the New York
City law helps eliminate inherent bias
in setting employee salaries last year
the Pew Research Center found that women
earned around 84 percent of what men
earned in 2020 that Gap has narrowed
significantly from 40 years ago when
women earned a around 64 percent of what
men did lawmakers and other supporters
hope laws like this will lead to more
Equitable workplaces will lead to more
fairness in the process and will help to
sort of level the playing field really
from the moment someone gets hired New
York's law did face pushback from
prominent business groups like The
partnership for New York City which said
the legislation was overly burdensome
for employers who needed more time to
comply with the new rules ultimately the
city did give companies more time and
the city pushed back the implementation
of a law from May until November of this
year right now the partnership for New
York City said most employers are on
board with this they may not be thrilled
about it but they're largely compliant
since the transparency law went into
effect companies have pursued a variety
of approaches to disclosure some
companies still aren't complying at all
others are posting really broad ranges
some companies have had ranges That Vary
only by five thousand dollars and so
it's a really mixed picture so far the
the roles that have attracted the most
attention are those with wide salary
ranges a trauma surgeon in the Mount
Sinai health system could earn anywhere
from three hundred and eighty four
thousand dollars to eight hundred
thousand dollars or more a tax executive
at pricewaterhousecoopers could make 158
thousand dollars or nearly triple that a
radiologist's position at another Mount
Sinai Hospital listed a job that could
pay as much as 525
000 or roughly half that amount at two
hundred and sixty thousand dollars one
of the really fuzzy parts of this law is
what constitutes a good faith range
because employers have made the case
that sometimes ranges need to be super
broad because they don't know who they
want to recruit for a role job Seekers
have said that more specific ranges are
more helpful the agency tasks with
enforcing the law is New York City's
Commission on human rights which will
rely mostly on citizen complaints to
investigate companies that post jobs
without the pay range listed it's
unclear whether the city's Commission on
human rights will will consider the
broad salary ranges a good faith attempt
to post salaries one co-sponsor of the
latest legislation told me that there
may need to be additional legislation
quote soonish to address the fact that
there are overly broad ranges this
council member said that he would like
to see a mechanism for example that
prevents ranges that are double the
minimum and maximum so example a range
from sixty thousand to a hundred and
twenty thousand he would see as
unacceptable
[Music]